With cross-filter directions, we have
the option for our filters to be single or bi-directional.
A single direction filter is usually our preferred option.
The reason is that the filter can be applied in the direction of
the relationship from one table to another, reliably and consistently.
This really will be your best option in most cases.
With both or a bi-directional relationship,
by default, the filters can be applied in either direction.
This can be okay if you have a small table,
but it doesn't necessarily scale and it does have
a performance impact that you have to take into account.
It's confusing for end-users,
and as you add additional tables to your data model,
you have to additionally account for this bi-directional component,
which can result in odd output for your reports and can be very
confusing for those end-users to understand how the information is being applied.
If you find that you can't apply
a single direction filter to get your desired end results.
Start by reviewing the data set first to confirm if indeed the
necessary base requirements for a one-to-many relationship are being satisfied.
Then review the guidance from Microsoft to
see if it makes sense to use a bi-directional filter.
A few specific use cases for
bi-directional filters include when you have a one-to-one relationship,
which we'll discuss in a bit,
when you need to bridge tables to be able
to ensure that relationships are aligning correctly,
such as when you're trying to avoid a many-to-many relationship,
and when you might have some unique slicer requirements.
Additionally, if you have
a dimension-to-dimension analysis where you're using a fact table as your bridge.
This is another reason that you may need to use a bi-directional filter.
In general, one-to-many relationships moving in a single direction,
are going to be our top choice.
I love them, and I think most people in
the Power BI community do because they're straightforward,
they're easy to understand and follow,
which is true both for you as you're developing it and your
end-users when it comes to interpreting the reports correctly.
They're predictable, so you know how the data is going to flow and how it's going to
perform based on different filters and measures built on top of the relationship.
As I mentioned, they play well with measures.
Power BI also does you a favor by validating a one-to-many relationship and alerting
you if it's not quite set up to provide the one-to-many relationship that you need,
something that doesn't always happen when you have, say,
a many-to-many relationship that you're trying to set up instead.